hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt's ein einfaches und wirklich
sehr schnelles rezept und zwar mache ich
gebackene schafskäse aus dem backofen
ich mache das zum beispiel immer mal
ganz gerne wenn ich einfach abends
zeugen keine lust mehr haben zu kochen
dann geht es ganz schnell ich kann vor
allem frische zutaten verwenden und es
ist auch ein etwas leichtes also man
kann zum beispiel entweder im boot mit
dazu essen oder das ganze einfach nur
essen ganz ohne kohlenhydrate zum
beispiel ich mach das jetzt heute für
zwei personen
und dafür brauche ich zwei päckchen
schafskäse und zwar haben die jeweils
200 gramm
hier sind mit peperoni es ein paar
oliven 200 gramm cocktailtomaten zwei
große knoblauchzehen oder vier kleine
zwiebeln eine gelbe paprika vier
esslöffel olivenöl
wer möchte kann gerne ein paar
schneeflocken oder frische chili und ich
habe ich noch die gewürze und zwar
jeweils einen esslöffel oregano minze
und rosmarin und alles getrocknet
den schafskäse habe ich jetzt bereits in
die auflaufform geld und darin werde ich
es auch zu bereiten
man kann das ganze aber auch zum
beispiel im krim zu bereiten und dann
entweder alufolie packen was ich
persönlich jetzt aber nicht so gut finde
mit alufolie zu kochen und zu backen
oder man kann so feste als ihn so offen
feste oder auch grillfeste schälchen
legen und das dann auf dem grill
schmeißen geht jetzt wirklich sehr
einfach ich muss eigentlich alles nur
noch klein schneiden
das heißt nehmen hier die peperoni und
ihr könnt auch noch weitere zutaten
nehmen die ihr gerne möchte
die werden jetzt klein geschnitten
die oliven werde ich jetzt entkernen
dafür muss ich sie zuerst einmal
halbieren
dann kann man den kleinen ganz einfach
rausnehmen
die tomaten werde ich jetzt alle
halbieren und natürlich könnte jetzt
hier auch große tomaten nehmen aber ich
finde die kleinen cocktailtomaten immer
viel aromatischer
die zwiebeln schneide ich jetzt in halb
bringe dafür halt zuerst einmal und
schmeißt sie dann nicht ganz so dünser
etwa drei millimeter dick
die paprika schneide ich jetzt auch
klein dafür schneidig unten immer den
boden weg und dann an den vier seiten
entlang und dann schneide ich sie in
kleine streifen oder ihr könnt auch
würfeln je nach dem beben gerne mögt
und die knoblauchzehen werde ich jetzt
in feine würfel schneiden
jetzt geht's eigentlich ganz schnell und
zwar kommen jetzt die zutaten alle
direkt über den schafskäse
das heißt so etwas kann man auch ganz
gut vorbereiten ihr könnt am abend
vorher zubereiten abdecken im
kühlschrank stellen
und am nächsten tag zum beispiel nach
der arbeit einfach in den backofen
schieben und vor allem finde ich jetzt
das hier farblich ganz toll
deswegen habe ich jetzt hier auch die
gelbe paprika gewählt und keine rote
wenn ihr könnt da wirklich rein machen
möchtet noch den knoblauch darüber
verteilen
jetzt kommt da das olivenöl drauf
dazu natürlich noch die kräuter
wer möchte kann jetzt noch mit etwas
pfeffer nachwürzen
jetzt nur noch ein bisschen mission
damit sich die gewürze und kräuter gut
verteilen können
jetzt kommt der schafskäse bei 200 grad
ober unterhitze ihnen vorgeheizten
backofen und muss für etwa 20 minuten
backen
der schatz des verzehrs ich habe ihn
noch etwa fünf bis zehn minuten im ofen
stehen lassen habe den ofen einfach
ausgemacht dann ist auch nicht mehr ganz
so heiß und die restwärme sagt dann wird
es noch besser wird
ihr könnt ihr natürlich auch direkt raus
nehmen dann ist das gemüse alles noch
richtig biss fest so jetzt richtig da
direkt mal eine portion an
also wie gesagt wenn man das jetzt als
hauptspeise ist dann reicht es für zwei
personen
und wenn es eine beilage oder zu sein
sondern auch für 34 personen
und ich reite noch ein paar scheiben
frisches brot mit dazu und dann ist es
heute unser abendessen und es ist
wirklich super schnell gemacht vor allem
wirklich sehr aromatisch durch den käse
da braucht man deswegen auch gar kein
salz also sobald man es von mir hat mal
genug salz im kompletten gericht und die
gewürze die passen halt wirklich
wirklich wirklich hervorragend mit dazu
ich habe ihnen versprochen aber egal
also wie gesagt ist es jetzt ein
schnelles einfaches und mediterranes
rezept und falls ihr jetzt auf hunger
bekommen habt dann schaut auf 6 - doch
da steht es noch mal ganz genau
wir lassen uns ist jetzt hier schmecken
und ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß
nachmachen und auch einen guten appetit
bis zum nächsten mal